[Music]
countless birds are now finishing their
spring migrations but it can be a
dangerous journey
in part because of man-made obstacles in
the u.s alone hundreds of millions of
birds
die each year after flying into
buildings in fact the phenomenon has
drastically reduced the population of
some bird species
now a group in philadelphia is doing
something about it
brook silva braga has their story
so here's a map of our route that we
take i can do it
blindfolded or drunk you know i've done
it so many times
before sunrise stephen machiavski is
searching center city philadelphia
for fallen birds during the night it's
very dark so they see that light they
want to get in there for whatever reason
they don't understand glass is hard
steven's daily report
and then the poor thing gets put in the
bag goes to the audubon society's keith
russell
we're also pleased to not find birds who
spent
15 years documenting these dead birds
to push philadelphia to help solve a
global problem
it's a factor in the decline of lots of
species
since 1970 we've lost about a third
of our birds the design of modern
buildings is partly to blame
they're often towers of reflective glass
that look to birds
like more open sky all these new
buildings they're just really glass and
glass in more glass
well that's true of most cities but if
they make a building that's basically a
big sheet of endless glass that means
they are not addressing this problem
that's creating a problem
definitely but it's a problem that got
little notice
in philadelphia until steven made his
rounds one morning last october
at one building i think i found about
300 birds
one building a cloudy night at the peak
of the fall migration
caused a massacre one guy brought a
dustpan of birds
he dumped it out in front of me there
were 75 birds in there some living and
a lot of dead words it was a rough day
but steven's photo of the slaughter made
headlines that got the notice of people
like corey gunselman
who manages one liberty place it's been
a problem honestly
we do notice the collisions that do
happen thanks
to a trade group building managers like
gunselman finally heard keith russell's
pitch
they could save birds and some energy by
turning off the exterior lighting that
seems to confuse birds at night
gunselman signed on and we have new
controls that we input
lights off at midnight only april
through may
this is what it has looked like this
spring as the most prominent buildings
in philadelphia's skyline
darken their lights and let the birds
follow the stars lights out philadelphia
follows similar programs
in nearly 40 other american cities they
use the stars in part to navigate
which might explain why they're
attracted to lights in some cases
jason wextein an ornithologist at the
academy of natural sciences in
philadelphia
says there's reason to think the dark
sky will help we know in other places
there are significant differences this
building mccormick place on the
chicago lakefront many fewer birds are
dying
but skyscrapers make up a tiny
percentage of all buildings
ordinary homes end up killing many more
birds
you find a few different ways to
approach yeah absolutely there's acid
etching here
so damien ruffner at philadelphia's
discovery center
has suggestions it comes in this
roll of tape small vinyl dots can break
up the reflection
so can p chord any vertical lines four
inches or less
but intentionally blocking a view that
can be a tough sell
we've seen these other solutions that go
right on the glass
etching dots these types of things are
any of those possibilities for you guys
that is something that we definitely
could look into the one thing is that we
don't want to take away the luster of
our beautiful double pane windows
that's the rub yeah right right but the
visibility keith russell cares most
about
is that his city finally seems to notice
its birds
this is something you've cared about for
a long time it must be gratifying to see
the general public start to care about
this too
it's really amazing after having worked
you know in this area for so long really
warms my heart
it makes me very proud to be a
philadelphian
there were no major bird strikes in
philadelphia this spring migration
the lights will be on again starting
tuesday but when the birds head back
south
in the fall keith russell already has a
promise that the brightest light over
center city
will again be the moon for cbs this
morning saturday brook silva bragg
who knew makes sense right yeah yeah and
then there's ways to
fix it yeah try to fix it for the future
i'm so glad they're thinking about it
right yeah